[موسيقى]
لماذا اصبح النظام الغذائي موضوعا محتدما
في عالم السياسه ولماذا اصبحت مناصره
القضايا البيئيه مصدر ازعاج للعديد من
السياسيين ومن قرر ان النباتيين واكلي
اللحوم على طرفي نقيد في مقياس التقدم
الاخلاقي او ان البيئي هو اكثر حرصا على
مستقبل الارض من غيره
لم تعد احتجاجات ناشطي البيئه احتجاجات
خفيفه او عابره فان تكون نباتيا او مناصرا
لقضيه المناخ اصبح جزءا من هويه يغذيها
تصاعد الاستقطاب السياسي الحاصل في العالم
تحت شعارات العداله الاجتماعيه وجد
النباتيون والبيئيون ارضيه مشتركه مع
الاحزاب اليساريه التي باتت قضاياها هدفا
للشعبوين واليمين الصاعد
وبين التطرف هنا وافكار متطرفه هناك تحولت
النباتيه وقضايا المناخ من قضايا ذات
اهداف ساميه الى تحركات ذات طابع سياسي
واسلوب حياه يعبر عن تلك الهويه
النباتيه هي فلسفه تحاول منح الحيوانات
حقوقا اساسيه تحديدا حقهم في جسدهم وحقهم
في المحافظه على حياتهم في اساسها هي
طريقه تعبير واسلوب تفكير يسعى الى الحد
بقدر الامكان من استغلال واستخدام
الحيوانات
اخشى من ان يدمر كل ما اعرفه واحبه كشخص
ما زال يافعا فان مستقبلي على المحك اشخاص
مثلي ليس لديهم رفاهيه الجلوس على الهامش
فيما امامنا الجيل المستقبل انا ساعيش هذا
المستقبل وانا مرعوبه من ان ازمه المناخ
ستقتلني وهي تقتل الناس بالفعل اليوم